he is the popular host of the dan
dockett show
which bears his name dan dockage on espn
1070 the fan in indianapolis
who wants to call in and i guess tell us
all about his indiana pacers and why
we should be talking about them good
morning dan
what are you talking about i just sent
you a text i'm listening to all this
nonsense today and i didn't hear
anything about the pacers i'm hearing
about teams like portland who can't beat
anybody all year
but everybody likes the one guy lillard
so you go nuts on that i'm listening all
these teams and i'm saying to myself dan
is a basketball guy dan patrick is a guy
that
professes to no basketball so i just
sent you a text how could there be no
talk of the pacers who have been by the
way
the smartest team i have seen in terms
of coaching and offensive basketball
uh in the rebooted nba for certain but
maybe all year long
i just don't know how healthy they are
dan that's a problem
that that is a problem that's why i say
coaching uh
you know what uh sabonis needs to take a
shot in his heel and let's go
i mean deer antler spray caught uh deer
antlers break cured my plantar fasciitis
it's just time to go you got to get you
you you just play with plantar fashion
it hurts like crazy right
but deer antler spray takes care of that
i don't even know if it's legal
but a trainer told me to take it i took
it and it was fine well the depot
uh went a little paul georgie on us he
went a little paul george went a little
diva on us for a little bit but he's
back
but i'm telling you dan tj warren people
talk about his shooting but
my man has been brilliant i mean he is
cutting he is backdooring he is getting
in the mid post i call it the bonzi
wells era
area and he made i think there's a kid
named wangu
who was from kansas state that was
trying to guard him the other day and he
made him look sick made him look like a
little kid
this team is good dan this team is smart
this team is good brogden
uh malcolm brogdon has missed and this
is bad he's missed
games because of eight different
ailments he's a tad fragile apparently
but when those three guys are on the
court and i'm talking about brogdon
oladipo
and tj warren then go get buckets like
like anybody else in the league yeah but
you said
if they are on the floor if they're on
the floor you're right
if they are on the floor and then you
throw in tj warren you got sabonis in
there yeah
yeah they could they could provide some
damage but you were you know
and i'm not one of those guys that poo
poos were a small market i mean
i don't need to talk about it i'm always
portland's a small market too and i'm
talking about portland today
yeah but they're not any good i mean
they have a one they're like an eight
seed you're talking about a pacer team
that's
they got a chance to be a four yeah but
look at the east and look at the west
oh i heard all that whining that's that
that is you made a great point
it was you that made a great point
nobody talked about it when bird was
running through the east and all of a
sudden
because for whatever the reason we're
all mad about lebron's success and i
don't understand
why do you sound surprised that i had a
great point
well it's because i know you dan and
it's just so rare
uh he's sitting there listening to you
and i heard blah blah blah blah blah and
all of a sudden it was a great point i
woke up almost spilled my coffee
who's gonna win the east dan
i'm milwaukee oh okay so then there's a
mood point
yeah kind of but you know i i remember
i'm on your show i get more listeners
whenever i'm on my on your show people
go damn i heard you on dan patrick i'm
going to tune in to your show today hey
i've been begging you what happened what
happened with larry bird in the pacers
none of that larry bird was done larry
bird was
done traveling i get it you got to come
up with a story and i don't know why no
no i'm just
i do i is was there a divorce there that
larry
what i saw is that larry didn't like the
fact that pacers weren't spending money
is that
yeah that no that's not absolutely not
okay
look okay let's be hon let's be honest
uh
everybody doesn't like something about
their employee okay and he may not have
liked that but that's not the reason he
stepped down
and larry uh larry's been very upfront
he's like look
you know when he coached he said i'm
only coaching for three years because
that's
all players want to listen to you is
three years and when he was a general
manager here locally he always talked
about when he he knew it was time to get
out when he couldn't travel
because he while he was a guy larry bird
was a guy that would sit in the front
row at portsmouth
dan and i'm i was there i've been there
i've seen he sits in the front row of
portsmouth while everybody's talking to
each other
larry was working and larry would fly
out and larry
he literally uh had his back was such
that he couldn't do what he wanted to do
and he said it the entire time he was
here when it gets too much and i know
that
that kevin and chad buchanan and the
rest are ready to go i'm out i'm going
i'm gonna stay around and be
an advisor if they need me but i'm going
and then i read that stuff and i'm like
number one why do we even bring that up
because
pacers will spend there's never really
been an issue it's just who
the the deal with spending dan as you
well know is two-sided
like i can say dan patrick i'm the
pacers i want to sign you which i never
would but i could say that
and somebody and you say well i don't
want to go there
it's too signing it's like recruiting
just because you offer money doesn't
mean people are coming and paul george
whatever paul whoa you were talking
about recruiting and offering money here
wow all right you got signed up i didn't
know that happened hey i gotta go here
goodbye all right that's dan dockitch
host of the dan donkey show on espn
1070.